it's so much more intimate than a laptop
and it's so much more capable than a
smartphone with this gorgeous large
display yeah if only things were that
clear now Steve phones are trying to be
tablets tablets are trying to be laptops
laptops are trying to be tablets but not
the tried and true iPad it remains
faithful to that original vision it's
trying to be a tablet which makes the
iPad 2 tops in some situations and way
behind in others let's start where we
use our iPads the most here probably
here and definitely here and the biggest
improvement in all these situations is
that the iPad air really lives up to its
name there's a substantial difference
between holding the 6.1 millimeter thin
air 2 and any of the early iPads with
one hand you'll still find them any
easier to hold up but this should happen
far less now though this is still a pain
one of my biggest complaints about the
iPad up until now is that every time I
want to read stuff outdoors I pretty
much have to do this the good news is
with the iPad 2 is that it cuts down
significantly on screen glare both
indoors and out in my outdoor test the
air to beat last year's air Samsung's
Tab s and Amazon's previous HDX
still it's nowhere near as good as an
e-reader outdoors and you'll have to
crank the brightness all the way up to
see the screen in sunlight which will
run down the battery faster and the
anti-reflective screen makes a great
though still enormous viewfinder for
taking shots with the 8 megapixel camera
it takes much crisper shots than before
in many cases as good as the ones I take
with my iPhone 6 but my phone's camera
is still the fastest for me to grab and
for commuters and travelers the air
still gets you 10 hours of battery life
though less if you're streaming video at
max brightness but if you're anything
like me you'll still bring your laptop
on a business trip and that's because
even as a basic work companion the air
is falling behind the competition the
iPads new a8x processor provides a
performance boost especially to the
iPads and mersive full screen apps which
are still far better than androids and
Windows but I wish I could see more apps
on the screen at the same time like a
can with the surface or the galaxy tab
and I'd really love a better way to type
Microsoft's $80 Universal mobile
keyboard is one of the best you can buy
but it won't prop up the screen well
enough and it doesn't double as a cover
the air 2 pushes the iPad forward and
all the ways and places that Apple
thinks we're using it and if you have an
older or heavier iPad on its last legs
this is definitely a worthy upgrade
especially if you're just looking for a
tablet but I'm still waiting for all
those advancements that push the iPad
beyond the one app at a time lean back
functionality that's been the case since
Steve Jobs 4 sat down on the couch